se rompió el libreto Y de qué manera en
esta copa mundo de Qatar 2022 Victoria
para Arabia Saudita contra Argentina por
dos a uno en este momento empiezan a
salir los hinchas del estadio luz sail
el estadio de la final de esta copa
mundo cerca de 90.000 aficionados con
una importante grada para los 10
estuvieron aquí para celebrar un triunfo
histórico para su país nunca antes le
hayan ganado Argentina lo hicieron hoy
en su primera aparición en una copa
mundo Argentina una de las aspirantes al
título que comenzó su andadura en este
partido con el pie derecho más bien Con
la bota izquierda de Lionel Messi que
transformó un penalti al minuto 10 para
adelantar a la Luis certificar ese
favoritismo sin embargo los saudíes el
equipo de renar tenía una idea muy clara
una línea en defensa muy adelantada y
aprovechar lo que llegará en ataque fue
así como en la primera parte Argentina
vio como le anularon hasta tres goles
por fuera de juego para el período
complementario ya con una Argentina que
fue de más A menos en la primera parte
los saudíes se dieron vuelta al marcador
en apenas
minutos goles de sale y Salem aldosar y
una pareja de delanteros que juegan
juntos en el algiral en el campeón de la
liga de Arabia Saudita y campeón de la
liga de campeones de Asia así fue como
los autitos al marcador a partir de ahí
esperar y aguantar los pocos arriones
poca creatividad la que vivimos en el
equipo argentino hoy despejamos una de
las grandes dudas del equipo del
escaloni como suplir la baja de Giovanny
lo hizo poniendo al papu Gómez
acompañado de Leandro paredes y Rodrigo
de Paul per Hugo muy poca creatividad en
el centro del campo de Argentina lo poco
que había era lo que intentaba Lionel
Messi que intentaba hacer éxito Con
combinar con lautaro Martínez panorama
ahora muy difícil para Argentina
complicado porque argentina se va a
medir ahora contra México que en el
turno de la noche va a jugar contra
Polonia y va a terminar precisamente su
andadura en esta fase de grupos por lo
menos contra Polonia Argentina que sabe
que es crucial terminar como primera de
grupo en este grupo c porque de aquí
saldrá el cruce con el grupo de Francia
la campeona del mundo